what's up my name is Samuel eat I'm a
property investor and about an hour ago
I posted on Twitter and said I'm gonna
be filming for the next two hours if you
have a property question please tweet an
answer on this video
so I've already have a load of questions
so here's what's gonna happen right now
I am gonna answer all the property
questions that I've come up but if you
have a question or if as I'm answering
you get like a question offer off a
question and you want me to answer then
just comment below in this video and
then I'll do my best to do another video
next week and answer your questions but
this week what we got what's coming
what's going on mr. Salim says when
doing rent to rent all rental serviced
accommodation deals what kind of things
do we need to be sure off like contracts
fire doors what kind of mortgage the
landlord is on ok great questions so
there's a lot there's a lot of things
but the the most important thing we're
doing a rate to rent deal is you need to
get the landlord on side or the owner on
side once the owners on side it's just
so much easier sometimes people they'll
look at a deal or they'll find a deal on
Rightmove are on gumtree on spare room
and then i think this could be a good
rent to rent opportunity and they'll do
so much research and due diligence on
the area on the house on the streets
even if it turns out to be perfect the
perfect deal they'll phone the landlord
or the owner and then just to be told oh
no not interested no thanks
so what's the point of working out all
the XYZ before you've even walked the
ABC and what does the ABC look like when
doing a rent to rent deal the ABC looks
like asking a landlord hey would you be
interested in receiving a guaranteed
rent from me this is the kind of amount
to be able to pay and then I'm going to
rent it out and I'll keep the I'll keep
the the difference but it means you've
got an easy life and I can take care of
the property if then I was like that
sounds really interesting I could do
that then you want to start looking to
you okay now he's on side now they're on
side what do you need to look at so it
depends on the property so of course if
you're renting it out and you're
changing the use of the property so if
it's currently a buy-to-let
and you're changing it to a HMO or a
serviced accommodation the mortgage on
the house if there is one it's going to
need to be fit for purpose so that's one
thing you need to watch for another one
is if again if you're changing the use
if it's if it's just a single at house
and you're turning into HMO then you
need to make sure that
the property it's compliant so how do
you fund out a lot of this stuff you can
find out on Google so if it's a single
letter and you're turning into h mo in
birmingham just google birmingham HMO
rules and you're going to send the
council website what are the rules does
there need to be fire doors how big do
the rooms need to be I guess I could
give you all of the rules in every city
to do with HMOs service de combination
but the very first thing is just pick up
the phone find a landlord that's open to
doing business and this is what's a
hands-off approach where you will be
able to turn the property from an
average producing rental property to a
super rent and once you've got the
landlord on side that's when you can
start figuring out all the stuff by
going on the correct counsel websites
serviced accommodation there's not so
much legislation around that if you're
in London there's a 90-day rule which
you need to watch out for so I guess
that's in simple forms and that's not
doing a whole video about it mr. salient
I hope that's helped answer your
question as the things you need to look
for with rent direct what else have we
got
you know schoo hey Samuel thanks for the
opportunity when calculating the return
on investment should I use interest only
or we payment to get return on
investment of over 20% or over okay the
answer that is when you're working out
the return on investment you just you're
just gonna work it out based on what
type of mortgage you're gonna get
personally I would always get interest
only and the reason I would do that is
because the difference between interest
only and the repayment mortgages you get
the mortgage another word for mortgage
is debt it's a loan however it's good
debt it assuming the house is good
because if you buy a house for a hundred
grand and you borrow seventy five
thousand pound to buy the house and
you're paying three percent interest on
that seventy five thousand pounds as
long as the interest payments are way
more than covered by the rent then and
you're in good profit then why are you
going to try and pay off that mortgage
as quickly as you can to pay them all
which off quickly or need to pay that 75
grand off all that money that you would
be paying to pay off the 75 grand you
should be using that money instead to
put down more down payments on more
houses which means you're going to
benefit off of the lead
bridge when the houses go up which means
your cash flow is going to be better of
course when you get interest only you
want to make sure that you fix the
interest rates you want to make sure
that you risk proof everything so
there's enough cushion and profit in the
deal your return on investment it just
depends on what what deal you get but if
you're able to get 20% return investment
or more than you're doing you're doing
pretty well so I hope that helps and if
you if you didn't understand any of that
and you're thinking my goodness Samuel
what are you talking about and you and
you want to ask more questions on that
comment below and I maybe I can do a
whole video about next time and do my
best to explain in more detail but
Thorburn I know you always say it's an
excuse to say I don't have the time but
I'm in the army and work long ish hours
away from home would you recommend
pursuing property with only a day and a
half free time yes I do have leave but
can only be taken at specific times but
it depends how hungry you are if you if
you want to be a property investor if
you're like I really want to do this
regardless of how busy you are you can
always find the time I mean I'm sure
that most people scroll through Facebook
I know you scroll through Twitter
because you saw this so maybe instead of
scrolling through Twitter and Facebook
you can scroll through Rightmove and
find deals you can literally do that
while you're on the toilet you know
you're going to just scroll through
Rightmove see what's come up that day in
your area on your patch and then you see
a couple houses these look good and then
your 20 minute lunch break pick up the
phone book a viewing you might only have
one day a month when you can view houses
but on that one day a month view 10
houses view 10 houses offer on
absolutely everything my brother all ten
of them so now why but that tender that
all ten of the houses are no good but if
you consistent you do that in the nooks
and crannies of life month on month out
you're going to get a deal and the
person that used the most house is the
person that makes the most phone calls
if the person is going to ultimately get
the most deals or make the most money
but if you're in the Army in your
absolutely choker and you sold out and
you doing what you doing and it can wait
and you think you know what I'm going to
be done with the Army in six months 12
months and that's what I'm going to go
hard on property then fine do that
there's no right or wrong but if you
really want it badly enough I think you
can always find the time ultimately
everybody has the same time a
billionaire businessman the Prime
Minister they have the same amount of
time
as you and I have so it's not about how
much time you have because we all have
the same time it's about how you use the
time that you have so I hope that helps
and good luck in your property journey
Joab Stewart says is that's three
questions okay good I like it if you
could advise your 19-yard self one piece
of advice what would it be it would be
learn to sell everything in sales I mean
when I started in property I thought I
need to know loads about property and I
need to learn actually property business
is a people business and when I say sell
I'm not talking about pushy slimy car
sale stuff I'm talking about how to get
people to do a deal with you I think
that'll be the biggest thing that I
would say people skills learning how to
sell and how to communicate with people
property business people business what
skills are essential to having today's
property business what skills need to
better negotiate need about calculate
the return on investment work out a good
deal you don't need to be great at math
but you just need to figure out the
formulas and third skill you didn't ask
for three skills but I'm gonna give you
three anyway third skill is being able
to make a decision based on logic rather
than feelings so really being a
level-headed so if you can do that I
think there's some good skills and how
do I make the most out of these answers
and go about actually applying them and
taking action go and view a house book
reviewing do a house talk to the agent
tell them what you want I mean
ultimately you can you can think about
it you can read books about it but if
you don't actually leave the house go
out the house and go to a property
networking event go out the house and
come on one of my programs or someone
else's training programs some of these
programs are free or you mean other
people that are successful in property
and when you put yourself in the right
environment you know people say oh you
just got lucky
there's no such thing as look look
happens when you put yourself in the
right place at the right time so you
just got to put yourself in the right
rooms leave the house what would you
recommend someone with an
entrepreneurial spirit but not knowing
what the next step to do Jayden
McCormack what I would say is firstly
congratulations because if you've got
the fire in your belly and the desire to
want to do this you're like 80% of the
way there because I I see so many people
and they just haven't even got the
motivation there's people in my family
there's like people that have been
little childhood friends and I'm like I
know if we think about property I know
the steps for you to be able to come
financially free I've done it over and
over I've helped thousands of people do
it but just do this but they haven't got
the fire in their belly
and then I even wanted a look at the
desire they're never going to be
successful so the fact that it burns and
you have the desired
jayden is fantastic what do you need to
what's the next step that you need to do
I thought what I would say is rather
than thinking really big picture you've
got this entrepreneurial spirit you
probably want to be a multimillionaire
or you want to be a billionaire you want
to have a hundred houses you want to
okay well what's the first deal that you
want to do you know what's the very
first deal where do you want to buy your
first house what does your first house
look like okay cool and then I'll just
set out to make that happen like on a
mission I'm gonna do everything I can to
get that made that happen of course you
can leave the education you're going to
need the support you can only the
network but just focus on the first deal
because your first deal is always your
hardest once you've done it once you can
then start scaling up and duplicating
and doing it over and over maybe
pictures good but don't don't if you
just stand looking at the mountain oh my
goodness it can be a bit scary but
you've just got to take that first step
and get that first deal so I hope that
helps okay we'll do one more question
this is Emmanuel Lewis what's up buddy I
hope you well how to handle objections
when selling property deals to investors
selling property deals to investors if
you're packaging deals and you're
selling them to investors how to handle
objections I wouldn't handle our
objections when you're selling a deal to
a new investor what you're trying to do
is you're trying to work out if your
deal your investment and the investor or
a good fit now you know everything about
the deal and they know everything about
themselves when you're speaking to an
investor what I do if I'm trying to sell
a deal I ask them questions
so Robin so I've got this great deal
that deals so good it's got five
bedrooms I've managed to negotiate it
below market value it's this it's this
it's this it's this isn't it great what
do you think
are you interested and then they're like
oh what about this and what about this
telling them about this and then they
start controlling the conversation by
asking you questions and then you're
answering all these questions you'll be
on the phone to them for an hour and a
half
they'll be picking your brain just to
say I'll go away and think about it
that's what most people that package
deals to investors that's normally what
happens instead you want to flip and
flip it around so you want to say hey
I've got this great investment property
however before I tell you about it
wouldn't be okay if I ask you some
questions to see if it's a good fit okay
thank you so firstly if the deal is
right are you in a position where you
can move straight away like some of
these investors that spend two and a
half hours with you on the phone asking
you all these frigging questions bro
they don't have any money so first thing
is if the deals right are you in a
position to move right away Oh
potentially potentially if the deals
right okay would you move would you be
able to secure today well I've just got
a few funds going on and you know I'm
just in conversations with my broker
okay that makes perfect sense give me a
call back when you have your funds in
place and when you've got you when
you've got your mortgage broker and you
and you're able to get the files give me
a call back thank you
you just saved yourself two and a half
hours that's how you got to do it once
they say yes if the deals like yes
absolutely would awesome thank you so
what would make a good deal for you Oh a
little bit need to be this this this
this all right cool
so let me take a little bit about the
property bum-bum-bum-bum-bum
how does that sound and you're just
taking control of the conversation and
then ultimately just asking them all
right awesome so this is the deal this
is the property seems to fit what you're
looking for you said you if it was the
right deal you'd want to go ahead what
else do you need to know from me and
sometimes getting all that questions up
front as well if they ask one question
and you answered then ask another
question and another question and
another question so sometimes you can
just say listen what do you need to know
for me and now said I need to know the
condition and how much the refurbs going
to cost okay
what else I also need to know you know
the quote for the refurb is that
guaranteed okay what else all the
questions up front great so if I can
answer all these questions and give you
everything you need are you in a
position to have to make a decision
today you just taking control of the
conversation for me this just comes of
experience is when I started deal
sourcing I'm in year 2016 I sold two
hundred and fifty six deals two hundred
and fifty six deals
I personally sold in the year of 2016 so
I've spoke to a lot of time wasters and
that's kind of how I've learned these
skills so it's a great question you
Manuel I hope that was that was helpful
a little bit at the crash course you see
me do this kind of stuff on stage you're
see me on the phone talking to agents
talking to new investors it will become
second nature for you you know because
as you see me do it as you start
practicing doing it you'll get better at
this it'll become easier to find deals
to sell deals
Samuel Stanley I'm gonna want to you
know and just because
I'm Sammy well he says I'm 16 can I do
deals yes I mean you can do deals at 16
listen there's a lot of people you know
like some of these questions saying like
I haven't got much time what would you
suggest I do rather than telling me
what's wrong
tell me what's right you know rather
than oh this is my problem only this age
or I've got this what have you got going
for you you didn't have to tell me 16
hey I'm super motivated I've got nothing
to lose I got all the time in the world
and I'm ready to view as many houses as
possible what advice would you give for
me it's a better question than I'm 16 I
don't care that you 16 dude maybe 16 so
you can't get a mortgage but instead of
I can't is how can i I mean I bought my
first house at 17 years old and I just
got I just got a family member to be a
guarantor for me put it in their name
anyway we're gonna wrap up if you
enjoyed that please do smash that like
button if you haven't subscribed to this
channel but you watch my videos and
shame on you now I'm only kidding do
subscribe though subscribe smash the
like button well see if you've got
questions and you'd like me to answer
your personal questions comment them
below I look forward to reading through
or weed as many as I can I'll answer as
many as I can and I look forward to
seeing you next time
[Music]